Miley Cyrus may be avoiding red-carpet  appearances but the singer isn't shy  about stepping out with her beau liam  hemsworth  unlike the luckiest ever the couple was  spotted flaunting their love in New York  City after attending the Thursday night  premiere of crisis in 16 her new show  and Woody Allen's first TV series Miley  and Liam looked adorable walking  hand-in-hand as they headed to their  hotel but could these sightings be the  rare times we see the wrecking ball  singer the voice coach vowed to never  walk another red carpet but cleared up  her bold statement on The Today Show  The Voice starts on on Monday he said to  Mike you know when do red carpets  anymore should I change the color of our  carpet for you it's really not about the  color of the carpet it's more about the  way that I especially women we get  yelled at to blow them a kiss and like I  don't feel like blowing you a kiss